[Music]
i
do not trust you he may
but i do not notice
my friends trust is not the issue today
spartan lock
it is my trust you
arbiter
[Music]
you are a hunter yes a seeker of things
that's not the official job title but
it's close enough
and now you hunt other spartans i'm not
so much hunting a spark
as i'm hunting the spartans
you see one one second
i was not told the identity of your prey
that is why i'm sharing it with you now
we're talking about trust after all
may i ask you something your people used
to call him demon
was that an insult or a compliment
an insult to be sure but one with a
modicum of respect he was indeed my
enemy
but in time i named him ally
even friend the events which forged this
bomb
[Music]
[Music]
there was only one ship one
are you sure yes they called it
the pillar
why was it not destroyed with the rest
of their fleet
it fled as we set fire to their planet
but i followed with all the ships in my
command
when you first saw halo were you blinded
by its majesty
blinded paralyzed dumb struck
no yet the humans were able to evade
your ships
land on the sacred ring and desecrate it
with their filthy footsteps
noble hierarchs surely you understand
that once the parasite attack
there will be order in this council
you were right to focus your attention
on the flood
but this demon this master chief by the
time i learned the demon's intent
there was nothing i could do this has
gone on long enough
make an example of this bundler the
council demands it
you are one of our most treasured
instruments
long have you led your fleet with honor
and distinction
but your inability to safeguard halo
was a colossal failure
i will continue my campaign against the
humans
no you will not
soon the great journey shall begin
but when it does the weight of your
heresy will stay your feet
and you shall be left behind
[Music]
the plating was about to fail there's
viscosity throughout the gel layer
optics totally fried and let's not even
talk about the power supply
you know how expensive this gear is son
tell that to the covenant
well i guess it was all obsolete anyway
your new suit's a mark six just came up
from songnam this morning
try and take it easy until you get used
to the upgrades
okay let's test your targeting first
thing please look at the top light
good now look at the bottom light all
right look at the top light again
that's it now the bottom one okay
everything checks out stand by i'm gonna
offline the inhibitors
move around a little get a feel for it
when you're ready come meet me by the
zapper
pay attention because i'm only going
over this once this station will test
your recharging energy shields
are you listening to me your new armor
shields are extremely resilient
very efficient bingo
as you can see they recharge a lot
faster
if your shields go down find some cover
wait for the meter to read fully charged
that or he can hide behind me you done
with my boy here master guns
i don't see any training wheels his
armor's working fine johnson
you're free to go son just remember take
things slow
don't worry i'll hold his hand
so johnson when you gonna tell me how
you made it back home in one piece
sorry guns it's classified my
ass well you can forget about those
adjustments to your a2 skull
well he's in a particularly fine mood
maybe lord hoard didn't give him
any invitation
earth haven't seen it in years
[Music]
when i shipped out for basic the orbital
defense grid was all
theory in politics now look
the cairo is just one of 300 geo sync
platforms
that mack gun can put around clean
through a covenant capital ship
[Music]
coordinated fire from the athens and the
malta nothing's getting past this battle
cluster in one piece
ships have been arriving all morning
nobody's saying much but i'll bet
something big is about to happen
[Applause]
you told me there wouldn't be any
cameras and you told me you were gonna
wear something nice
folks need heroes chief to give them
hope
so smile what's up well we still got
something to smile about
[Music]
ah
if they came to hear me big they will be
disappointed
are you sure
[Music]
[Applause]
gentlemen we're lucky to have you back
go ahead cortana another whisper sir
near io
we have probes and root i apologize but
we're going to have to make this quick
you look nice thank you
sergeant major the colonial cross is
awarded for acts of singular
daring and devotion for a soldier of the
united earth space corps heresy
let him be an example for all who would
break down
commander miranda keys your father's
actions were in keeping with the highest
traditions of military service
his bravery in the face of impossible
odds reflects great credit
upon himself and the unsc
the navy has lost one of its best
[Music]
slip space ruptures directly off our
battle cluster show me
15 covenant capital ships holding
position just outside the kill zone this
is fleet admiral harper
we are engaging the enemy negative
admiral form a defensive perimeter
around the cluster
commander get to your ship link up with
the fleet yes sir
you have the mack gun cortana as soon as
they come in range open up
gladly something's not right
the fleet that destroyed reach was 50
times this size
sir additional contacts sporting craft
and lots of them
they're going to try to take our mack
guns offline give their capital ships a
straight shot at earth
master chief defend this station yes sir
i need a weapon right this way
all hands report to battle station
this is not a drill i repeat this
is not a drill
how's it going malta stand by their last
check your targets watch the crossfire
they're in standard formation little
bastards up front big ones in back
good luck cairo
[Music]
as soon as that door opens
[Music]
real quick
[Music]
let him have it
real pressure door
open weapon blocker
[Music]
i need a squad in habitat alpha asap
[Music]
with responsibility for security
[Applause]
[Music]
new pressure door
wow
break for impact
so
come on
find the borders point of entry chief
cut them off at the source
[Music]
security station 4 is under attack
hey check it out the malt has already
driven up his borders
malta what is your status over
i don't believe it they're retreating we
won
this is bad real bad
[Music]
oh
[Music]
alert have reached the port maxwell
[Music]
borders in section 7.
all right guys
one
[Music]
[Music]
oh hey they're leaving the athens
cortana assessment that explosion came
from inside the athens
same as the malta the covenant must have
brought something with them
a bomb and they sure as hell brought one
here
chief find it
all non-combat personnel the pressure
hell out of my zone
[Music]
delta
hang on everyone
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
i need a squad
[Applause]
the fire team for terminal too
come on chief this way
[Music]
all hands
[Music]
sir borders have reached the fire
control center they have a bomb
can you defuse it yes but i'll need the
chief's help to make contact with the
detonator
chief get to the bomb double time
cortana prioritize targets and fire at
will
[Music]
first echelon you're with me blanket
those cruisers take them out one by one
second echelon keep those carriers busy
i'm going loud
alert border port drive out
evacuations
report to evacuations
chief we don't have much time
the carriers are breaking through sir
they're heading straight for the cairo
cortana concentrate your fire on the
first carrier
admiral do what you can against the
second everyone form up
follow my lead
the first carrier completely ignored us
sir blew through the malta's debris
field and headed straight for earth
just so you know there are quite a few
elites guarding the bomb you may need to
get creative
foreign
[Music]
so
me inside your head now
[Music]
how much time was left you don't want to
know
cairo this is an ember clad the carrier
shield is down i'm in position and ready
for immediate assault
negative commander not against a ship
that size not on your own
sir permission to leave the station for
what purpose master chief
to give the covenant back their bomb
permission granted
i know what you're thinking and it's
crazy so
stay here unfortunately for us both i
like
crazy
[Music]
hmm
just one question what if you miss
i won't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for a brick he flew pretty good
chief get inside gear up we're taking
this fight to the surface
you